[Inaudible].
I want to talk about positivity or hear you talk about positivity.
Because for instance, I was,
I was reading a piece in variety that seemed to me to indicate that you are a
master of managing energy and avoiding energy leaks.
And, uh, for instance,
the decision to allow your children to get to know your, uh, their grandfather,
your father,
the quote that stuck out to me was it takes too much time and energy to keep
hate alive. And for those people who don't know, I mean,
your father was an addict. You ha you've,
you've spoken about him publicly before a contentious relationship. Uh,
how have you developed that positivity? Was that, uh, mostly from your mom?
Uh, how do you think about that.
When you, when you come from the bomb and you work your way
up to when you work your way up to the place that some people refer to as the
top, I mean, what, what do I have to be angry about?
What do I have to really and complain about
and Harper, you know what I mean? Like, I, I,
I really do come from none of them. I'm a,
I'm a part of a very small percentage. So,
and understanding that and knowing that the things that are supposed to
act as triggers to things that are supposed to be
life-changing threatening, you know, altering, um,
are just lessons. It's just education.
It's it's stories for lack of a better word. You know,
you got an amazing story under your belt,
and I don't choose to stay in
one particular paragraph, uh,
of my story. It's a long story. And you know,
the life is as long as of course,
we are all given the chance for it to be, uh,
because that's something that we have no control.
We only tried to enhance the opportunity of longevity
or success. We don't have no control,
you walk outside and something could happen. Boom. And that's it.
So I just have a realistic approach and understanding to
that, I've come from nothing. I got something I'm appreciative of my,
something. I don't look at this something as if I'm supposed to have it,
because that's not how it works. I'm very fortunate and blessed to,
it could all go away if it did. And I had to start all over again.
That's life. I don't harp on it.
I don't and complain about the things that I can't change and the things that
you can change. Why spend if you're going to change it.
Yeah. You know what I mean? So when you, when you look at, for example,
relationship, uh, with me and my father,
did my father up. Yeah. Uh,
my father get himself clean and straight. Yeah.
As my father feel bad about some of the stuff that he did. Yeah.
Could you still be angry at the lack of parenting that was done or the
time that was spent? Yeah. But why it doesn't,
it doesn't change. It,
it doesn't change anything that happened. It doesn't,
it doesn't make it right. You know what I mean?
Like you don't that, that anger that you're,
that you're giving off into that is not going to change these things.
So that's energy that I feel like I can put into something
else.
That's energy that I feel like I can get a lot more use out of
that energy. That would have been negative. I'll find a way to say,
you know what I do forgive you. And I mean that and that life now,
hopefully it's better for us if it's not, I know that it's not because of me.
I don't like putting myself in a position to easily be affected. You know,
I think life is too short. It's too short.
And if you just spend time being affected all the time,
those are tough days, man. If you're bothered all the time,
there's a lot of to be bothered about the day. You can be bothered a lot of.
If you're the person that's really bothered, then how,
how pleasant are you to be around?
If there's just so much anger and so much
negative energy,
I just choose the opposite direct and approach. And I mean,
that doesn't make me perfect. I'm nowhere near perfect. I done up.
I don't do stupid and I've apologized and VAT can be,
uh, you know, those apologies can be accepted then. Great. It's fantastic.
If they can't, why can't do anything about that?
I can't put any more energy into the things that I've tried to do or make right.
If you choose to still feel a certain way, God bless you.
I'm going to keep living. That's my attitude.